[Music]
foreign
you think you know what is real
what is it
what is light
what is dark
now forget all you know come with me
Willow
[Music]
we're looking for the sorcerer Willow
it was told that once long ago you
defeated the forces of evil you remind
me of your mother
I thought I could prevent all this
I was wrong
my brother was abducted the world needs
you again it needs your magic follow me
we must go beyond the edge of our world
into the unknown
I need your help just like old times
ready horses
our true enemy is still out there
rallying the forces of evil
the only thing standing in his path is
us I'm going to enjoy this I feel
thinking what I'm thinking so am I I
love that very much take him to my tent
and make sure he's tied up I don't know
see that kind of sounds like we're on
the same page
when I was a kid I used to play up being
a sorcerer visiting strange worlds
fighting monsters
never thought I'd actually really do it
what the hell is that
trolls I'm so miffed
we have to worry
same as last time
with my friends
[Music]